well there is new controversy now over
the president's handling of the pandemic
now that fox news has confirmed the
biden administration is prioritizing
race and ethnicity when it comes to
giving out some potentially life-saving
coveted treatments i'm harris faulkner
you're watching outnumbered
joining me now my co-host emily compagno
kaylee mcinerney fox nation host tommy
laron former utah congressman and fox
news contributor jason chaffetz it's
going to be a great hour good to see
everybody
according to the new guidance updated in
just december the fda says there are a
number of factors to consider when
determining who is at high risk as a
patient and who will be
eligible for certain coveted treatments
age and obesity
are the top ones but the fda says
race and ethnicity should be on that
list the new guidance reading this way
other medical conditions or factors for
example race or
ethnicity may also place individual
patients at high risk for progression to
severe covet 19. now i want to point out
that unless somebody got a medical
degree over the weekend none of us is
doctors but we all live in the real
world and jason when when you're
asking people to do things and mandating
that people do things
it makes prioritizing other people
specifically difficult i would imagine
in this environment
i i i can't believe we're in a place in
this country where triage is going to be
based on race and ethnicity i i just
don't understand that so much for barack
obama's hey we're not the red state
we're we're not the blue states we're
the united states i mean so much for
that this president and this
administration is doing more to divide
us than you can possibly imagine i just
don't i i can't imagine there's any any
medical ethicist who would come back and
say this is the proper way to do it and
if they're going to do it on the
treatment i wonder what it would be like
if we said hey maybe on the prophylactic
measures maybe what if we said based on
race and ethnicity
those people should be wearing masks are
you kidding me that is so absurd and
ridiculous if you that's
this is the kind of discussion we're
gravitating to thanks fda that's really
interesting because what you're saying
is well if we're going to tell people to
be safe do we only tell certain people
to be safe and mouth score i mean that
is a fascinating question well doctors
have a thought on this particularly a
black doctor that's who i wanted to talk
to former surgeon general dr jerome
adams under president trump
last hour on the focus watch
we can't blame and shame people based on
who they voted for or the color of their
skin what we need to do is really demand
of this administration they're getting
more testing available that they're
getting more treatments available so
that we don't have to make these
horrible choices
so kaylee the conversation had gotten to
that point because i asked this simple
question two people show up at the er
one is black one is white they're both
obese they both have morbid conditions
uh preconditions you're going to pick
the person with a darker hue
why
yeah
it makes no sense um well said by dr
jerome adams i worked with him um he is
a man who always says it right and
indeed he did so just there but harris
what's interesting to me is how states
are operationalizing this you have the
fda obviously you know a federal entity
suggesting that race should be a basis
for potentially administering
therapeutics and what's happening on the
state levels is they're really grabbing
onto this in utah they do a risk
assessment by points and you get two
extra points solely based on the color
of your skin so not your risk factor not
comorbidities just by the color of your
skin you hop on over to minnesota and
they literally say this fda's
acknowledgment means that race and
ethnicity alone
alone so apart from risk
apart from underlying health conditions
may be considered in determining
eligibility for therapeutics that is a
stunning claim to make and they're
seizing on that federal government
language and it got to the point where i
was reading in the new york post that a
staten island doctor went to go give
prescriptions administer prescriptions
for two patients and the pharmacist
literally said to him before i authorize
these prescriptions disclose the
person's race now the two patients did
happen to be white they did happen to
get the therapeutics and then the
pharmacy says we're just collecting this
data for reporting purposes to the city
but what a scary place that now to get a
prescription they're asking you to
disclose your race stunning
what are they doing with that
information though that they're
collecting it right for the city but
what is the city doing with that
information
i mean that that i had not read that um
you know tommy
jason brought up something that i think
is so critical and it's about division
in this country right so if you want to
look at someone and say well they
probably don't have health care because
of where they fall economically let's
pull that person forth because their
you know preconditions are probably off
the charts that's one thing
but but race and ethnicity then throw
this into a whole different category of
division
what this feels like to me is
reparations disguised as health and
safety and a poor attempt by the
democrats to once again race bait and
pander you know for a party that says
they want unity they're certainly going
backwards on that and they're actually
sharing more ideas for segregation and
more ways to break us apart but you have
to look at the motivation for this why
do they want americans black versus
white straight versus gay rich versus
poor why do they want these divisions in
this country what is the benefit for
democrats well i think it's pretty easy
if we're all fighting each other if we
all think that we are fighting our
fellow americans then we're not paying
attention to what this administration is
doing and how it's failing our country
but harris you and i have talked about
this on this show before we want to talk
about health and safety we want to talk
about certain groups that have more
vulnerabilities let's talk about that
and let's talk about health and safety
in these communities communities that
don't have access to to good food
communities that don't prioritize
exercise let's also keep in mind that
these same democrats who are now
preaching this health and safety and
have for the last two years spend over a
year trying to close down gyms because
they consider them a covert risk so we
want to talk about keeping people
healthy of all races let's start there
and realize how many times the
government has failed and maybe more
government is not the answer because
they certainly don't seem to know what
they're doing so emily i want to talk to
you about the add-ons on this guidance
because what tommy is talking about is
very true and i and i read it from the
guidance right as we were getting into
this hour
so obesity and age are like really up
there
okay
the add-ins parenthetically were race
and ethnicity as an example of something
that they'd like to to also have on the
list
legally talk to me about that and and
when does that become discrimination so
harris faulkner and and six foot four
cute guys she married
white guy walk into the er with our
biracial children and sometimes it's
hard to tell who's what
um and one gets taken before the other
or i get taken do you think i'm really
going to go ahead of my biracial
children to get treatment the answer is
no like where are we going legally with
this
right so when you have a law or an
ordinance or any type of rule that
discriminates on the basis of race then
that is subject to strict scrutiny which
means that that that entity the
government has to prove that there's a
compelling state interest and it must be
narrowly tailored this law to the the
state interest for it to succeed for it
to pass constitutional muster and here
as we've sort of been talking about in
this ongoing conversation this is a
massively over broad answer to what is a
legitimate concern but the legitimate
concern is two degrees back so just to
echo my colleagues comments here it is
correct that people of color and
minority communities are overrepresented
of those who have kidney disease
diabetes obesity but it's not because of
their of their melatonin in their skin
it is because of societal factors like
access to healthcare access to adequate
nutrition and exercise and the like
historically and statistically speaking
so it's not about their actual race or
ethnicity it's the systemic things in
the society that prevent them from
getting that same access so this kind of
thing is totally overbought absolutely
not narrowly tailored and therefore
unconstitutional if i can add one more
thing very briefly uh the the risk ratio
that you mentioned you know it tops out
for age at 10.6 with those 85 and older
yes and those are actually represented
by more white people so it's a really
difficult complex analysis but quite
clear when you see it for what it is and
adding on to kaylee's anecdote from
staten island you know that physician
rightly so he said he was absolutely
appalled and he said never in my career
have i ever been asked what race my
patient was it's a sorry state of times
yeah i mean all of it and we have to get
real about who's vaxxed and who's not
it's not all about politics i said this
last hour there are tremendous amount of
people who are
black and brown as we say black and
hispanic and other makeups
that chose not to get vaccinated they
don't trust the government there are a
whole host of issues are we going after
that because this administration said
it's a pandemic of the unboxed it can't
just be about politics because the
numbers don't bear out i went on brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now